let's talk about how women we just
believe things now I'm not saying
feminine men don't believe things too
but I'm saying women we always go to the
extreme where you know we'll leave these
social movements and just believe them
like it's actually quite crazy so one of
these crazy social movements is veganism
and as you guys would probably guess
vegan activist women are just the most
reasonable the most
agreeable you know they really like they
just tell people to get their points
across and all they're doing is just
being very reasonable and nice so there
was a clip that came from a vegan
protest let's pull the clip
there are male vegan activists too
but it's the women that are that are
screaming it's so funny once you start
to like look at modern women as children
because like that's like a kid's temper
tantrum I heard a guy say once that
women stop maturing once they like hit a
certain age where they start to get
attention from men so it's like some
women that's 14 some women that's 17
some women that's 16.
um and you know once I saw this I really
couldn't unsee it and you know it was
funny
one time this is a a Side Story my
grandma I went
um when I was in high school I got in
trouble so my mom sent me to my
grandma's house in Wisconsin and it was
so funny because my grand my grandma was
a widow at this time and she took me to
this like karaoke bar and at the karaoke
bar it was like her and the other widows
it's very interesting men like die
typically younger or like at an early
age than women and so the women like
it's like a new dating scene in like the
60s and 70s it's very interesting
they'll be like dating someone and
they'll just like die like I'm like
they'll literally be going on a date and
they're like oh I I dated him but then
he died but it was so interesting
because the way they would speak about
the guys I remember being like 16 and
thinking they sounded like high
schoolers I remember I remember having
this thought like they kind of talk like
me and my friends do
and
you know no no shade to Grandma you know
rest in peace loved my grandma but but
it's just kind of funny where I realized
I'm like women we really just
stay the same age like mentally for a
lifetime like men kind of grow and
mature you can you can definitely tell
the difference talking to a young man an
older man and you used to be able to
tell the difference talking to a young
woman and an older woman but it's so
interesting because like guys this whole
theme of this today is like these
younger women act exactly like the older
women like it's just this delusion where
okay if I pretended to be A different
race people would think I was crazy like
they would think I was insane
um if I pretend to be a different gender
I mean some people don't think you're
crazy but like that's a small like most
people think you're kind of crazy right
if you're really trans and pretending to
be a different gender
but old women pretending to be young
women is socially acceptable why is it
okay for a 45 year old woman to pretend
to be a 25 year old woman but it would
be crazy if me a 26 year old woman
pretended to be a baby wouldn't that be
crazy like if I started saying goo goo
gaga but for some reason these older
women can dress like younger women
these older women can
move like younger women go to the clubs
with younger women date
men that are like 20 years younger than
them
um treat their kids as accessories
that's the other thing I realized so
many women want to have the kid not
because they love the kid not because
they want to be a wife and a mother and
a helpmate to a man but because
they want like an accessory for
Instagram
I swear I swear I believe this like
Instagram has brainwashed us so much
that we almost like live our lives for
Instagram and you'll see especially
tradcon women they'll uh they'll get
married and their husband almost becomes
like a prop for their brand and same
with their kids it's like they almost
like don't get married and have kids
because they want to and they like love
their family it just becomes like part
of the brand and we almost have a
society that's like moving and making
decisions for Instagram because
everything's so women-led so like women
are leading families women are making
purchasing decisions women have all the
voting power but it's so interesting
because women are living for Instagram
and making decisions for Instagram you
see women taking vacations for Instagram
you see women getting married for
Instagram you see women having children
for Instagram you see women going to
clubs being a part of social events for
Instagram like we used to have a
community we used to build community and
we would do it for fulfillment but now
it's literally for Instagram
but it's like weird we have this whole
society like
I don't know in history people would
kind of do what made sense for society
and you wonder why we have all these
like
I don't know this craziness all these
like mental health issues like you know
millionaire men cucking out their wife
you wonder why we have all these women
that have it made and then they think
they can do better like
it's so interesting because we always
talk about the men's porn addiction but
we never talk about the women's social
media addiction and as women we are like
so addicted to social media that we are
literally running Society based on
social media we're making decisions for
society based on social media and we
should be pissed off that the men are
lying to us
that other women are lying to us that
older women are lying to us and the
media and companies are lying to us to
take our money because that's all they
care about they don't care about the
family They Don't Care About Us all they
want to do is make money off of us and
it's really like a sad way that
society's going now a lot of people want
to come at me but it's like don't shoot
the messenger I'm not blind and this
isn't just a small percentage of women I
I would say probably the majority of
women are addicted to social media and
we could talk about the men's porn
addiction right I'm not saying that
doesn't exist but I don't think men are
making life decisions based on porn
but women are making life decisions
based on what social media says and
they're worried more about the opinion
of social media than the opinion of
their husband
they're worried more about the like
think about that they're worried more
about the opinion of social media
than their husband but maybe I'm crazy
right so I ended every time maybe I am
just cherry picking and you know the
women are of great quality
um with our head on straight you know
and I actually I wanted to add one thing
women crave more than anything guidance
and I think that's like you know what
does a child need growing up guidance
what do women need we need guidance and
I know it's like people will say that's
offensive to like refer to women as
children but guys like come on look at
look at us
look at what we do when we have no
guidance so when they take the father
out of the home then you have us
believing in all these stupid social
movements you have us living our lives
for Instagram we condition men to think
that they are dumber than us to think
that they have no say and to think that
they should not guide us when they
absolutely should women we need guidance
because we're emotional we process
things with our emotion we we just we
get all amped up and stressed out like
men are a lot more calm they're a lot
more problem solved they're a lot more
problem solving oriented and that's
really what we're seeing a lack of when
you take the fathers out of the home is
guidance young men need it but
especially the difference is young men
get to a point where they can think for
themselves young women
I promise to God we do not think for
ourselves you might think you think for
yourself
you do not we can be so programmed by
Propaganda and the media we're just
different and it's not a bad thing guys
like in in history this is how we would
survive you had to you had to adapt to
the group in order to survive but the
problem is the media companies have
taken what used to help us survive and
weaponized it so that we literally are
destroying the family structure